[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain a sci-fi comedy movie called
the one
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
in the not-so-distant future human
society has been divided into two parts
one which is inhabited by the rich and
the other one by the poor the rich
people who live a lavish and comfortable
lifestyle stay above the line whereas
the not so fortunate and working class
people live on the other side of it the
line is a real barrier that was created
by the government to separate the two
sets of people at the start of the movie
we are shown an aerial shot of the
society that has been divided into two
parts on the left side we have a
futuristic looking city whereas the
right side represents a dilapidated and
crowded area where people struggle to
put food on their table every day after
this we are shown the line which acts as
a border between the two parts like any
other international border the line is
heavily guarded with armed personnel and
strict security if one passes the
security checks they are free to roam
around on the other side of the border a
man named stu is then seen crossing the
line and moving to the city area where
he uses his ai device to know about the
time after getting to know that he's
late he starts running and soon reaches
a fancy restaurant there a couple is
complaining about how the other side of
the line is scary and unsafe to live in
soon stu approaches his friend who
recently got engaged with a man after
the introductions stu starts chugging
his favorite beer which his friends find
weird turns out that stu was born below
the line and lived there until he was
18. his family moved to the other side
when his mother made a famous app and
got rich from it we also get to know
that the people above the line are
assigned dates right from their birth
but the people on the other side have to
find their own dates hence stu is yet to
find a girlfriend he also fears that he
will die alone join the club stu as the
group is talking they are approached by
a stranger who confirms that he was
eavesdropping on their conversation he
then mentions a dating site called the
one that's the one which guarantees to
find the perfect match for someone in
fact he met his wife through the same
site and has been living happily ever
since after this the strange man opens
his tablet and starts showing the
company's advertisement in the ad a man
gives a brief introduction about the
company he says that at najari labs dr
najari uses a combination of
specifically picked questions and dna
tests to provide the perfect partner aka
the one that's the one for an interested
candidate following this he starts
dancing in a weird manner which is
longer than the actual advertisement
itself gotta get the video to that 10
minute mark for youtube in the next
scene stu is at najari labs where he is
staring at the same creepy dance on the
screen just then he is approached by
that same man but when asked about the
commercial he responds that he has no
idea of it this confuses stu but he
decides to ignore it after this stu is
taken inside the lab where he is hooked
onto some wires and prepped for
interrogation the man then explains the
whole procedure he mentions that he will
ask stu some questions while the device
will extract and scan his dna the
results of the two tests will provide
the information to determine the one
that's the one for stu although nervous
stu agrees and the procedure starts for
the first question the man asks stu his
favorite number but stu takes three
attempts to finalize his answer hearing
this the man warns stu that he must give
honest answers so that the perfect match
can be found for him if stu is a furry
now's the time to speak up after this
the man asks some very irrelevant
questions which are totally not related
to the subject despite this stu tries
his best to answer them after a while
the procedure is finally over and stu is
asked to sign over a legal document he
then pays the fee through his digital
hands and gets notified that his partner
will be arriving at his home sharp at
midnight the quick processing time stuns
stu but he thanks the man and departs
without any further questions later stu
is at his luxurious apartment where he
is all dressed up and waiting for his
partner to arrive it is 11 45 pm and stu
is practicing his conversation skills
time passes by and it is 15 past
midnight but still no one arrives at the
door this frustrates stu so he opens his
jacket and drops to the couch as he is
contemplating his decision a sudden ring
is heard at the door stu gets delighted
and immediately goes to welcome his
guest but to his dismay it turns out to
be an elderly man the man introduces
himself as bert and walks inside but stu
is still confused about his arrival when
asked about why he's here burnt reveals
that he was sent as the one that's the
one stu becomes enraged and complains
that there has been a mix-up and bert
agrees to this since both of them claim
to be straight they become certain about
the fault and plan on getting a refund
stew then breaks down and starts
explaining his pitiful life on how he
can never get a life partner hearing
this bert consoles him and the two start
talking about their life below the line
turns out that burt was a car dealer
there before he got transferred above
the line after the conversation as bert
prepares to leave stu invites him to
stay for dinner and the old man agrees
they then decide to go to al's
restaurant which is situated below the
line surprisingly both the men love the
place and are regular customers there
later they reach the line where they are
thoroughly checked by a bunch of
security personnel after passing the
checks they head towards the restaurant
and start conversing about their lives
even the movies they watch are similar
just then the restaurant in charge al
comes to take their order and both of
them reply at the same time egg white
omelet you like eggs too let's bang
furthermore both of them like the yolks
separated and on the side here we get to
know that the men have a lot of uncanny
similarities between them after
finishing their dinner they greet each
other and head separate directions the
next day stu goes to najari labs and
starts calling out for the man when no
one responds he enters a room and finds
dr najari sleeping suddenly bert
approaches from behind and this startles
stew causing him to scream burt also
gets frightened and he too starts
screaming at the top of his voice the
noise awakens dr najari and
unsurprisingly he starts screaming as
well when the duo asks dr najari for an
explanation he simply rushes inside a
vacuum tube and teleports away as a
result bert and stu are left alone and
they eventually decide to go out and
have grilled cheese in a drastic turn of
events the duo end up having a romance
and after this they start spending
quality time with each other they are
deeply in love and it seems like they
are a match made in heaven in the next
scene stu takes bert to meet his parents
but the latter seems to be nervous about
it however stu calms him down saying he
likes him the way he is after a while
bert finally meets up with his parents
and surprisingly they are impressed by
him the three then discuss in the living
hall and start singing songs from the
past which stu can't seem to comprehend
following this stu thanks his parents
for accepting bird despite his old age
however the parents reply that they are
happy to have one more old fogey in the
house bert then hands over the present
he bought for stu's mother and it turns
out to be a mechanical owl the duo love
it very much and they request stu and
burt to stay for dinner to which they
agree
now it's time for stu to meet up with
burt's family which consists of his two
children stu is nervous about the
meeting but burt assures him that it
will be less daunting than meeting his
parents soon they enter the house and
stew is approached by bert's children
pleisa and bouge pleisa is excited about
meeting stu and she even compliments his
good lucks however bougee declines
stew's handshake and storms to the
backyard first my dad named me bouge now
this seeing this stu decides to confront
bouche and talk about his problem in the
backyard stu introduces himself as bouge
rides up on a small pony stu tries his
best to strike up a conversation but
bouche seems uninterested in it hence he
picks up a safe ball and asks bouge to
play with him the latter hesitates at
first but after a lot of convincing he
agrees while they are playing bouche
starts opening up about his past and how
he misses his deceased mother hearing
this stu comes up with a motivational
speech and eventually manages to win
bouge over in this way both stu and
bert's families support the relationship
six months pass by and the couple are
now married and living together in the
same house one night when the couple is
going on with their daily lives someone
suddenly rings their doorbell after
opening the door the same guy from the
the one that's the one commercial comes
inside however he claims that he is a
different person and only a technician
for nijari labs the man then claims that
he doesn't normally go house to house
but in this instance something special
has occurred he then reveals that when
dr najari tallied the duo's data into
his machine he
made a mistake as a result he declares
that bert and stu are not each other's
one that's the one he then shows stu's
match which turns out to be a beautiful
girl and also bert's match which
surprisingly is al from al's diner when
the couple try to dispute his claim
saying that they are married now dr
najari suddenly approaches from behind
and says that science cannot be disputed
he then states that there is much more
at stake so the couple have to separate
and live with their new partners he also
calls his bodyguards who were standing
in the other room the whole time left
with no other choice the couple
eventually decide to separate and meet
their new partners stu packs all of his
belongings along with a photograph of
him and bird and then departs the place
in the next scene a distraught stew
wanders around the city later he meets
up with his new girlfriend but she seems
to dislike all of his habits including
eating the eggs with the yolks left out
later while they are at the park stu
puts some ice cream on her face like
bert did to him but this annoys her here
stu realizes that he is simply wasting
his time so he runs to stop burt who is
about to leave the city he hurriedly
reaches the futuristic station called
the podport but gets there a bit late as
bert enters inside and teleports to
another city devastated he starts
blaming himself for being late but right
then byrd approaches him from behind
claiming that he's always late too turns
out that the other man who left in the
pod was not bert after all the two then
embrace each other and decide on living
below the line as a couple in the last
scene it is revealed that the strange
man from the the one that's the one
commercial and the technician from
nijari labs are indeed two separate
people
uh what
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching